dubbing close calculation of losses
from a friend's house explosions dead
on I took people made a car and we
flew
screaming in fear from this horror but you
seized
everything safely taken out I
am repairing cars the
car is in excellent
condition now I thought only saving my
family when its known to a safe
place
seeing the fear and horror of other people
who were walking mothers no trying to save themselves
hundreds of eyes looked looking for salvation
I don’t understand what to do I’m a
person of help
I realized that I had to save them
I scored this car Volga
passing poor previously unfortunate people
and tried to withdraw
remembering the words of the great man
Winston  Churchill's war is when
completely harmless people die for the interests of others,
and
remembering the words of my grandfather that it is better to
die than to be afraid or afraid and live
all my life,
I decided that the blades of the year under
these mines mouths under these cities are
living dead to save ours
in absolutely nothing
my fighting girlfriend's mother's guilty year  olgi
that I took out
I changed them
for the fifth time the cats were cut splinter
it car
fit 9 people you can
imagine I am
shelled
every day every day I tried to make at
least three meals
from Germany
to take out from Mariupol because there the
most affected people
would be scary  don’t go out the trip and of
course the voyage right away it’s
not a pity the package the package is
burning at home around the explosions of the deceased,
but I took people planted bridges and we
flew
screaming from the fears of this horror you seized
safe
take the most necessary water eggs for the
children to feed something and also
hid in this trunk  I
saved a man because he says I want to leave
and he was sitting here, I have him, but we are trying to collect everything in the
apiary for fetters
so that my car
works so that I can buy spare parts for the
car, you know, I constantly
repaired my savior machine
with the money that people give me in order
to  she went saved I will return
that salty year and I will bring out more looking for
people
think th  about the
end of the war,
my typewriter has the best for my
husband soda and
put up a garage and say we have a rest you
saved so many times you walk
white you have to go somewhere